siamo quindi arrivati alla seconda parte
in i troll face quest ora che la seconda
parte di attacco quando fatto in due
perché il primo era talmente bello ma
fanno anche due ma certo questo io spero
di trovare i riferimenti agli horror
perché nello scorso episodio trovati per
di mente tutti
paola allora siamo in una casetta mela
allegra allegra c'è qualcosa nel
corridoio immagine non c'erano lights
out caressa 100 101 shining prendevo
fosse lights out valorizzato che spegne
la luce e compagni va al terribile
non credo che questo sia molto più
terrificante che loro c'è in serbo
shining quindi va bene così
next cioè queste sono di shining vero
spero di no
e questa una cazzata comunque meglio di
sì andiamo avanti e cioè la tizia che si
lava molto bene questo è il classico
queste scream no a michael myers michael
myers 1 col cucchiaio mi servirebbe
spegnere la doccia no sono più brutta di
te senza il make up
quindi è che provi a uccidermi sono io
che ti ammazzo stato mi è sfruttato un
altro occhio a cosa
ma come vero ero nascosto col make up di
certo il a tutti abbiamo tre occhi ma ci
mettiamo il mascara non si vede questo
non ho idea di cosa possa essere
l'attacco dei cactus malvagi mandarino
lo so ma se non ho capito che ora da
questo ma cosa macro 7 bene questa
neanche questo lo capisco sinceramente
però va beh c'è una molto classic
ricchissima se non ho idea di che ho
rose ma c'è chi sa chi la cosa però ha
fatto niente
no ragazzi basta non ho fatto niente non
ho fatto nulla stavolta porto demonio
prima ci ha messo due ore questa
l'attacco delle zanzare e mutante
immagino bella deve trascinare da dove
tristezza solo una zanzara mutante il
più sopra la torta che una torta di
merda che non era la sola prova la mamma
voglio solo vedere cosa succedeva
sonohra mangiavo niente schizzinoso la
bene ragazzi sto per divina roba della
quale non vado molto fiero credo vs
arrivato talmente avanti da riuscire a
capire cosa fare e prima ancora di
perdere quindi ho voluto la mia mente
per renderla stupida in modo da capire
se questo è sinister credo che lì sono
tutti ragazzi corrente tutti ignoranti
sono un malato
sicuramente le parti alla pratica che
non deve uscire da qui devo fare
qualcosa del pretore sicuramente a
[Musica]
ma come sono riuscito mettiamo la manina
e poi spaventiamo ciao era meglio fare
una cosa tu spiega vita questa manovra
che uscirà questo non è possibile
ci voglio provare anche io non faccio
molta strada davanti con questo non so
cosa sia ma dio santo copri coi piedi in
testa
e gesù è vero e jason low cost cross
klein e jason con le ciabatte fantastico
al posto della maschera comunque verona
scaligera non è un atro questo è freddie
krueger chiaro scrisse un marshmallow è
solo mangiavini ok ho vinto o perso non
devo fare questo va bene a il
marshmallow e la faccia di freddy
krueger in realtà se trovi in faccia
tutto lo spazio di fascia e proprio la
faccia di freddy krueger se ci pensate
marshmallow corpo ci sta perché tutto
bruciato quindi devi devi devi sparare
mi sono veramente cagato e questa cosa
triste questa è la faccia di fare
economia perfetto questo e3 di fuga
l'avevo capito
oddio questo eden un micali sono tutti
legati all'aspetto hayden un oppure
insidious con la tipa quella blu va
benissimo
e uno dei due ragazzi che vi sia più del
insidious problema toglie che cazzo ne
frega da dove mi sono pagato due volte
la quei dieci secondi e siamo in un
trasferisco s ragazzini figuratevi se
dovessi invece non spegnere la candela
era esempio
se cagato addosso lei molto bene sono
fiero di me cosa diavolo dovrebbe essere
questo non lo so storia di vampiri che
mangiano sushi sushi di vampiri non ha
sbagliato se mangiassi pesce invece che
lui se ti mangia invece ama quelle un
quadro non è il cameriere che penso
fosse vivo web
ok allora niente il coso pipistrello e
vai via vai via
oddio io credo fortemente che questi
giochi siano pensati da una scimmia che
quando caga concepisce un altro fisco è
stata nessuno me lo spiego adesso lui si
mangia a noi e la tua magia del pesce
eroe ottimo fingersi in una foca brutta
con un cappello perché c'é la carife
uscì perché non ci ho pensato prima
assieme alle 11 ragazzi questo è lo
squalo
credo che bronzo esattamente quello che
farei in una continua situazione del
genere molto bravo è che cosa dovrebbe
sbloccarmi scusa proviamoci
[Musica]
sono un dentista è il dillo subito è che
ne so noi andiamo avanti
tutto chiaro quindi basti real time gli
squali non sono cattivi come mangiare le
persone in mare ma voglio semplicemente
di far silenti tutto qua va beh questo è
che sarà difficile da indovinare
credo che io debba far scoppiare a noi
tipo in app il palloncino fanno volare
un santo di dio
ciao
9 dic elettrica era quello olio provati
tutti tranne quello quello che alla fine
era giusto ok va bene non si lavano così
i denti si spazzano dall'altra parte io
sono figlio di dentisti
non è vero bravo esattamente quello che
pensavo come le molle giorno questo è un
horror quali horror dove capitan uncino
chi esce dal cesso scusatemi che mi
sfugge proprio uncino gli occhi lucino
era lucino mettici lo spazzolino adesso
dentro lucino è uno sturalavandini ho
suonato accesso ragazzi e ciò anche
diploma pensate voi che culo o questa
non ha idea però questo qua ha gli
stessi colori di sully di mons secondo
che non c'entra niente prove c'è una
sporca 10 cosa facciamo qua ok deve
andarci addosso la macchina aveva capito
perché non so cliccando sulla macchina
società ma su di lei può andare indietro
indietro di che si muove leggermente non
ho capito il perché ha forse mi devo
avvicinare piano piano piano
questo ragazzi era bellissimo questo era
bene era non ci sarei mai che fu voci
arrivato completamente per culo
bellissimo ci sta questo e godzilla
no non è così la the ring la cassetta
sputo la cassetta previa casetta piccata
no ma vola la bambina di the ring non
sapevo ragazzi io non me ne vado finché
uno stacco lavorare porco il demonio
dopo la corrente sono solo mette
un'altra cassetto faccia mente la casa
non celiachia videoregistratore dove la
si guarda ndaw questo ragazzo approvata
nel indizi non bastano inizino vi dice
che devo schiacciare sul televisore ma
devo continuare a schiacciare tutte le
ore se in castelli che lo sapevo lo
sapevo che dovevo leva la corrente lo
sapevo non sapevo geniale ma io ho
schiacciato sulla presa direttamente
quindi va bene
questo non l'ho mai visto sembrano i
nemici di rai mentre non so se lo
ricordate
ok pro mousavi invita tutti a reggio
anche con l'indizio non funziona male
che tutto che devo fare così perché vari
consigli come quando chiedevo ricopiare
matematica ai miei amici non copiamo
quando comunque tre almeno dami
consiglio giusto ok a sono gli amici
della foresta con pippi calzelunghe
chiaramente
il mio cervello sta perdendo del
quoziente intellettivo tutti insieme o
anche il livello segreto ragazzi perché
non ci facciamo mancare nulla provare
poi a sta parlando agli importi da the
mist dei mister belli d oro socialisti
ragazzi denis che bellissimo dei visti è
veramente uno dei migliori ora ormai
fatti sono 90 non ricordo stasera curata
il livello segreto è sempre più
difficile mannaia canti
[Musica]